Hello again everyone, this is Steve Gilbert.
Welcome to Lecture 14, where we're going to talk
about exceptions and templates.
So in Lecture 13, we talked about assumptions.
Assumptions are things that you believe should be true.
So when you write a function, you assume certain things
about the inputs.
When you write a function, you assume certain things
about the output.
We call those preconditions and postconditions.
So a precondition is something that's true about the inputs,
and a postcondition is something that should
be true about the outputs.
Now, when we write these preconditions
and postconditions, we use some doxygen tags
to document them so that people who call your function
know what to expect.
So for instance, for the square root function,
they should know that n should be greater or equal to 0.
In other words, if you pass a negative number to square root,
you are not going to get the expected output.
The postcondition and the @return tags
are going to tell you what you should expect to return.
So you can use @return and @post kind of interchangeably
to talk about the return value.
You'd use things like @exception.
Now, you can use @post to tell what
should happen if the precondition is violated.
So what is @post for square root?
Well, @post for square root is it
will return not a number in that case
if you violate the precondition.
So we have five things we can do with a precondition violation.
First, we could try and fix it.
So think again about square root.
If you were writing the square root function,
you might decide if you get a negative number,
you'll just return 0 in that case.
Now, that would fix the problem of getting not a number, which
is what they actually do in the square root function.
But it wouldn't really return the right answer.
In other words, you'd be giving it the wrong answer.
The square root of minus 1 is not 0.
And so we generally don't want to do that.
Although, when you're first programming,
frequently you're taught to think about what
will happen if this happens.
So let's make sure that it doesn't crash and so forth.
But we really don't want to do that.
Secondly, we can terminate with an error message.
So just stop the program when the error occurs
and stop.
Now, sometimes we want to do that,
and sometimes we don't want to do that.
For instance, we certainly wouldn't
want to do that if someone types in the wrong URL
in your web browser.
You wouldn't want to terminate and say, sorry,
Chrome's decided you've typed in the wrong URL.
We're not going to send you to that page.
But sometimes that's the right thing to do.
If your program discovers an error that's
going to propagate further and further and further
inside your code-- in other words,
if one of the preconditions is violated,
the program continuing to run is not really a good idea.
And so if the problem is caused by a mistake
that you have made in your programming-- in other words,
something that you logically believe should be true--
you do want to terminate.
And I'll talk about how you do that in a second.
Thirdly, we could return an error code.
And that's kind of what square root does.
Square root returns a non-valid number
if its precondition is violated.
It returns a special number called not a number.
You could throw an exception, which allows the programmer
to catch it.
Now, you can't do anything about what square root returns.
But if a function throws an exception, like s2i,
you could actually catch it.
Or finally, we could ignore the problem altogether
and just hope for the best.
So we obviously don't want to ignore it.
We generally don't want to fix it silently,
unless the fix is just immaterial,
like for something in the user interface that
wouldn't be that big a deal.
So that leaves us with these three--
terminate with an error message, return an error code,
throw an exception.
So as I mentioned in the last lecture,
if you have a programming error, we
want to use a statement called assert, which terminates
and tells you what line the error occurred on.
So for instance, if I'm writing a function sum
between lower and upper, any time
that function is called with a lower that
is greater than upper, I have an error that won't make sense.
Now, if I returned 0 from that-- in other words,
if I kind of fixed it silently, or I wrote my algorithm
so the function returns 0 when lower was greater than upper--
I really have a programming error.
And I haven't found that error.
In other words, I'm calling the function
when lower is greater than upper.
And I really kind of didn't want that to happen.
So you might decide, this logically can never happen.
If I call the function with lower greater than upper,
I've made a mistake.
And so I would like the program to automatically stop
when that occurs and tell me, Steve,
you've made a mistake on line 42 in foo.cpp.
And so that's what the assert statement does.
It allows you to put in statements
that enforce the logic that you're
trying to put inside your code.
Commercial code is literally littered with assertions.
One of the nice things about assertions
is that when you're developing the code,
you can put them in, check your bugs,
when you're testing it and running it.
And then when you ship your code, you can remove them.
So you're not having the overhead of the if statements
that the assert statement generates.
All right, so let's talk about the other kinds of errors,
though--
errors that are not caused by you, the programmer,
errors caused by exceptional but anticipated circumstances.
If you live in the Arctic and you live in an igloo,
you should expect that at some time
you're going to see a polar bear at your front door.
You should anticipate that.
It's exceptional.
That's not the normal.
But you should anticipate it.
What kind of things can we anticipate when programming?
Well, is the user ever going to type in a file name
incorrectly?
Sure.
Is the disk ever going to be full when
you're saving a file?
Sure.
Now, those kinds of errors, we could just
return an error code.
But the problem with an error code
is the user or the programmer has to check the error code.
These are a little more serious.
If the disk is full when saving a file,
you simply can't go on.
You'll lose data.
If the user types a file name incorrectly,
the program simply won't work.
And so an exception is for something
that you want to handle and you want to force yourself
to handle, or you want to force programmers
using your class to handle.
This should be handled by throwing an exception.
So you all know how functions work.
Functions take inputs, they process the inputs,
and they produce an output.
They return that output.
But actually, functions have a second way of returning.
So you can think of the return the normal channel,
but the exception is a back channel.
So we can say, if the program normally works--
and let's use the function called s2i.
s2i takes a string and returns an integer,
just like our parseInt function we're going to write today does.
So we're going to write a version of s2i.
And if I pass--
that stands for string to integer.
If I pass the string that contains the character 1,
it will convert that string to an integer and return 1.
If I pass a string that contains the word 1, the English word
1, instead of returning the integer,
it returns via this back channel called throwing an exception.
And that exception is thrown to the function that handled it.
Actually, it's thrown not necessarily
to the function that called it, like the return statement is,
the statement that called it.
It's thrown to the nearest exception handler.
So an exception handler is a special kind
of block of code that we'll look at shortly.
Now, in C++, the throwing an exception looks like this.
If I detected an error condition,
just throw some object.
Now, again, this is similar to a return statement
from inside a function, but it doesn't
return to the calling function, but to an error handler.
If there is no error handler, then it
will keep bubbling up to the very main function
where it'll find a default handler.
And that default handler will terminate the program,
and it will look almost exactly like an assertion.
Look almost exactly like an assertion.
OK, so you might have seen these in Java.
You may have had to handle them in Java.
And in Java, in C++, any kind of object
may be thrown as an exception.
Now, Java has a whole class hierarchy
of exceptions that are rooted in the class called throwable.
Throwable has two subclasses, error and exception.
In C++, we could throw an integer
if we wanted to catch different kinds of error codes.
So you could catch int, and then you
could check to see if it's 1, do this.
If it's 2, do that.
If it's 3, do that, and so forth.
You could throw a C++ string.
Notice the little s after the double quotes.
We could throw a C string as well.
That would be a different kinds of things.
So we could throw a C++ string.
We could throw one of the standard library exception
classes.
So this is similar to Java with its throwable, runtime
exception, index out of bounds exception, and so forth.
We could throw an illegal argument
and construct an illegal argument object
and say that the illegal argument was A.
Now, the standard library includes, just like Java,
a variety of exception classes.
If you want to include those, you have to include a header.
They're not automatically included, just
like everything in C++.
And the most common ones are things like domain error,
the parameters outside the valid range, invalid argument,
the argument was invalid for some reason, or out of range.
The argument's not in expected range.
So that's how we throw.
That's how we signal from our function
that an error has occurred.
If we're calling the function, how do we
intercept and handle that?
And so to intercept and handle exceptions,
we do almost the same thing you would do in Java and Python.
Python has try, except, I think.
Java has try, catch.
So you place the code that can fail inside a try block.
So we're going to call the function parseInt.
We're going to pass it a string.
That string may contain the digit 1,
but it may also contain the word 1.
And if it contains the word 1, rather than setting x
to a value at all, what we'll do is we'll throw an exception.
And any statements that follow this parseInt
will be jumped over until we get to a catch block.
So the catch block has to say what kind of exception
it's going to throw.
Now, this exception, we're going to decide what it throws.
So you catch a specific type of exception.
You always want to catch it by reference.
So in this case, if we say the argument was invalid
and we're catching that, we'd say catch invalid argument ref
e.
And then it would jump.
If it failed, it would not do the next statement.
It would jump from there to this invalid argument.
Let me close Zoom.
Keeps popping up, saying it wants me to log in.
It would jump from this parseInt when it failed.
It wouldn't assign anything to x.
And it would jump down here to this catch,
see if the exception that was thrown was this type.
If it was, it would set the exception argument,
and we would go into the exception altogether.
So let's try a couple of those exercises,
just so you get a feel for try-catch.
So these are on part A of our exercises.
There's an empty try-catch block here,
which will do the catching.
But it's up to us to redesign the code to make use of it.
Now, there's an imaginary roster of students,
which we'll pretend is dynamic, but for the purpose
of this exercise, is hard-coded.
You'll find the names in the source code.
And the roster's implemented as an unordered map.
You haven't learned how to use that,
but you really don't need to know how to use it for that.
When running the program, you're asked to enter a name.
After doing so, it will use the map
to print out the age of that student.
Unfortunately, if the user enters
a name that's not on the roster, it
is not on the roster, an exception is thrown,
which we don't handle, and the program just terminates.
So we're going to do two modifications to this.
We're going to catch the exception so that it can least
exit gracefully, and write out a nice error telling the user
that the name they entered doesn't exist.
We're going to print the actual name they entered back at them.
So let's do this first exercise.
So here's our unordered map.
So a map simply is a key, like the name here, and the age.
So this is mapping a student's names to their ages.
So this code is in a bit of a sorry state.
If we enter a name inside here, and the name
is Fred, which is not on our list, it will, when we do this,
this line, student name at, will throw an exception.
Will throw an exception.
And so this is the try catch that we want to use.
That's the necessary syntax.
So we are going to throw an error.
We're going to put this code.
So that part's going to be outside.
We're going to write try.
And then I'm going to take this line-- actually,
let me just copy this part out.
So it gave us the syntax here.
I'm just going to bring the catch here.
And we're going to catch if it's out of range.
And let me fix that.
And we're going to say, C error, sorry, comma, name
was not there.
I don't know if that's the correct error message.
OK, so notice the code that may fail
is placed inside our try block.
This code cannot fail.
It's placed inside a try block.
So let's try it.
And I left out a set of arrows there.
So I had a syntax error.
Oops, and I put the arrows in the wrong place.
Still had a syntax error.
I left off a semicolon.
I'm all thumbs today.
OK, enter a name, John.
John is 16 years old.
OK, so yeah, so I didn't have-- so it was sorry, comma,
Jake does not exist.
So let's look at John.
John is found, prints out its name,
and then skips over the catch block.
Catch block is never executed.
Jake throws an exception here.
We skip over the name is age years old.
We jump from line 24 to line 27, and we print out,
sorry, name does not exist.
Same thing with Lawrence.
Zoltan exists, so that works OK.
So this is try, catch.
Now let's do the second one.
So we want to do it so that the program validates
by using the try, catch.
Doesn't just print out an error message,
and it should do it continuously until they actually
enter a valid name.
So we don't have to do much difference here.
What we're going to do is we're going
to need to put all this code inside a do while block.
A do while.
So do, enter a name.
Then we're going to put our try block.
Try block.
And we'll create a Boolean value.
So that's going to have to be created
before the do while loop.
So Boole equals or done, false.
If we succeed and don't throw an exception,
we're going to set done equal to true.
So now we're going to put in our catch block.
And exactly the same code we had before.
Here, sorry, name does not exist.
And here's the end of our do.
And here's the while.
Not done.
OK.
So we're going to continue doing that while it's not done.
We're going to enter in a name, print in the name.
We're going to try it.
If we try it and we succeed, if we get down to line 28,
we're going to set done to true.
This will fail and we'll be through.
So let's try it.
So enter name John.
That worked fine.
We just entered the name, set done to true.
We hit our while loop and we're finished.
Here we entered a name Jake.
Nope.
Sorry, name does not exist.
It went up and it asked us to enter a name again.
Now in this case, the code check doesn't
show what it really looks like.
So we would not enter Jake, Bill, and Paul.
We'd enter Jake.
It would say enter a name.
We'd enter Bill here.
Enter a name.
We'd enter Paul.
Paul's 31 years old.
So notice this just repeats until it
gives us the correct answer.
It gives us the correct answer.
OK, let's actually write some code now.
And so go over and open.
And open in IC14B, open int helper.h and int helper.cpp.
I don't know why it's not letting me open both those.
Maybe because I haven't added any code to it.
Let me add code to that one and do the cpp.
OK.
OK, let's open a terminal on that.
And then let me close that.
OK, so these are the two functions we're going to write.
So let's look at those.
The first function, parseInt, is going
to convert a string to an integer.
So int n equals parseInt 42.
If it can't succeed, it's going to throw an exception.
The second function is going to read an int from the console.
So this is int n equals readInt.
Enter a number.
The prompt is optional.
And just like the last problem we did,
it's going to keep prompting until integer values are
entered.
So we're going to start by documenting
the functions in the header.
Then we're going to have invalid input to parseInt
by throwing an exception.
And then we're going to validate our logic with assert.
Now there's a little bit more information
on this in the handout over here.
So we're going to include the preconditions, postconditions,
and exceptions.
We're going to throw an invalid argument with an error message
when parseInt fails.
We use parseInt in an endless loop
and try catch to implement readInt.
And we'll use assert to check that we never
reach the end of readInt.
And I will just test this.
I'll break out of my loop to make sure
that the assertion works.
Make sure that the assertion works.
So let's document the function.
And so parseInt-- we didn't put this in a namespace.
We could have.
So converts a string to an integer.
At param s-- let me change that to str.
I don't like just using single letter names.
str is the string-- so str is the string to convert.
Let's put in our precondition at pre.
At pre, we'll contain valid digits, optional sign.
Let's do minus 1, 2, 3 to give the optional sign there.
So that tells us the precondition.
That says what we assume is going
to be true about parseInt at post or at return
or at exception.
Let's use at exception because that's a valid argument.
If invalid argument, if str contains--
contains invalid characters.
And we might want to put more about what that possibly is.
And at return, the integer result.
So that's pretty good for the documentation.
So readInt-- it's an integer from the console
or standard input.
At param prompt will be displayed
if passed with a colon.
OK, at return, and the post condition here
is keeps prompting.
So there's our documentation.
There's our documentation.
So let's take this.
Let's go over to inhelper.cpp.
Let's put your Canvas ID on it.
Let's write the functions here.
You can leave the docs inside here if you want.
You don't have to.
Let's put the body on it.
Let's stub it.
Let's return a value in each case.
We're stubbing it, just making a skeleton.
Let's go ahead and try it.
OK, so number one, we made a syntax error.
And that is when we have default arguments,
you need to remove them in the implementation.
Let's try it again.
So parseInt is what's being tested here.
parseInt is what's being tested here.
So let's actually do something.
And parseInt didn't work at all.
So let's go over and look at how we get parseInt to work.
So what we need to do for parseInt
is we need a string stream.
So we're going to take a input string stream.
And we're going to initialize that with the parameter str.
Then we're going to create an int n.
And we're going to read into n.
OK.
Now, if n is not failed--
and you can write that as if not n fail.
So if not n fail, in other words, if n's still good.
And n is at EOF, then we're simply going to return n.
This simply means, did we consume everything
inside that string?
We're at end of file.
That's true.
This says, well, we didn't read any invalid characters.
So if both of those are the case, that's true.
Now, it's possible that someone could enter a string like this.
So notice that the n will automatically
skip this whitespace.
But it will still stop right on this character.
That means we're not at end of file.
And so to fix that, we have to read the whitespace again.
So in whitespace.
And now we're just going to repeat this statement.
Now, I'm sure this kind of bothers you.
And it bothers me a lot, too.
Because really what I'd like to do is do this.
I'd like to read the input and the whitespace all
in one statement.
That works under the GCC library we're doing.
It works on Unix.
Again, the GCC library we're using.
It works on Windows, the Windows libraries.
It doesn't work on the Mac libraries.
And actually, since we're not programming this in Mac,
I'm just going to use it anyway.
On the Mac libraries, unfortunately, it fails.
So we're going to read the number.
If there's any whitespace, we're going to read it.
So this one's going to read OK.
This one-- actually, let me comment that out.
This one is going to throw an exception.
That's what we want to happen.
That should throw an exception.
And so we're going to throw invalid argument.
[TYPING]
Or something else like that.
Now, let's come down here to run.
Let's comment out those first two.
And let's just do make run.
Make run.
So I'm going to pull that right there.
I'm going to clean that and do make run.
Student testing 125.
It works.
Now, if we've done everything correctly,
this one should throw an exception.
So make run.
Terminate after throwing an instance
of standard invalid argument.
5.2 is not an integer.
15.2 is not an integer.
So that's pretty cool, right?
So this is the default handler when we didn't catch anything.
In other words, we didn't put this in a try catch.
If you don't put it in a try catch, it just terminates.
So through an instance of standard invalid argument.
Let's comment out that line again.
And then let's go to our second one
up here, which is read int.
So for read int, we're going to prompt the display
if it exists.
So if not prompt empty.
Or you can write it if prompt not equal to quote, quote.
This is a little less efficient than-- because prompt empty.
Prompt not equal to quote, quote has to first convert
the quote, quote into a string.
It has to use the relational operator
to find if it's not equal.
So prompt empty is just going to return true or false
immediately.
So that's probably a little better.
But this probably is easier for people to understand.
If the prompt is not empty, we're
going to see out the prompt.
And if prompt back is not equal to a space,
and prompt back is not equal to a colon,
let's just say a space.
If that's not the case, then I'm going
to print out a colon or space.
In other words, I want to get the input away from the prompt.
OK.
Now let's convert the thing.
So we're going to say return parsing.
Oh, we need to read the value.
So string value.
Oh, we need to--
yeah.
Yeah, we're going to use parseInt.
We're going to return parseInt.
parseInt value.
OK.
So this is the basic structure.
Let's come down here and uncomment these two lines.
Let's do make run on it.
OK.
Enter a number.
And notice how it added my colon.
So notice my prompt is enter a number.
It adds the colon in this space after it
and puts my input there.
I'll enter 245.
And you enter 245.
Now let me run it again.
2.45.
It threw an exception.
So we want, if this value is bad,
that's going to return-- that's going to throw an exception.
So we're going to put this whole thing in an endless loop.
File, true.
So this will return out of the loop.
Then we'll put this part.
Enter inside a try.
Catch.
And I'm not going to print an error message.
Oh, maybe I will.
Maybe I'll print an error message.
OK.
I don't know if the testing actually wants this error
message.
OK.
So this is like what we did in the code check exercise.
So we have a do while or a while true.
And if we can parse the value, we get out.
If not, we print out, sorry, that's not an integer.
And we go back and prompt for it again.
So let's try that now with our run here.
So make run.
Enter a number, 1.
Sorry, 1 is not an integer.
Enter a number, 45.2.
Sorry, 45.2 is not an integer.
75.
OK, and we entered 75.
Now once we've done that, we can check the parse
in here with the testing.
So make test.
So it works perfectly fine.
So up here, you're going to--
oh, we want to do one more thing.
We want to break out of the loop to see
that our assertion works.
And we haven't put in an assertion.
So an assertion is something that is impossible.
So what's impossible?
This loop is while true.
It's impossible for me to get here.
So I'm just going to say assert false.
This is saying this is unreachable.
That is unreachable.
Now what I'm going to do is I'm going
to make a mistake in my code.
Remember, assertions are determined
to catch mistakes in your code.
I can say that my intention, my assumption,
is that I should never, ever be able to get
to this line of code.
It's unreachable.
But what if I inadvertently say break?
Like that.
So this is a piece of error in my code now.
And when I do-- let's do make run again.
And when I do 1, if I do 42, it works fine.
But if I do 1, it throws the exception.
But also, I actually had an assertion.
So I'd go look at line 55.
When I looked at line 55, it would say,
oh, this should be unreachable, or this is unreachable.
And then I'd look back and try and find my error.
I'd see, how did I possibly get to that code?
And maybe I'd put it in the debugger or so forth.
So I'm going to comment that out.
So this is the kind of thing you want to put in your statement.
Now, false normally would put some kind of condition.
False just means, if you ever get to this line of code,
throw the exception, or throw the assertion,
trigger the assertion at that point.
All right.
So those were two good exercises to get you
into throwing exceptions.
The last topic we're going to talk about today
is function templates.
So look at this function.
So I have a function smaller, takes two integers, a and b,
and uses the conditional operator,
return the smaller of a or b.
So if a is less than b, it returns a.
Otherwise, it returns b.
Notice this, actually, the algorithm that she uses
will return b if they're identical, not a.
So perhaps it would have been better
if you wanted to return a if it was the smaller.
In other words, first or smaller would say a less than
or equal to b, return a.
What if we want this function, though,
to work for something other than an integer?
Will it work for a double?
In other words, if we called smaller 1.5, 1.75, well,
first it would truncate them, right?
It wouldn't really work for other types.
So if I wanted smaller of 3.5 and 7.5,
I'd always get back an int here.
If I wanted smaller of zebra and ant, it wouldn't work at all.
So how would we fix that?
How would we fix it?
Well, option one is just write an overloaded function
for each type.
So here's a smaller for a for double,
and here's a smaller for string.
And then our main function on the previous page works.
The downside, the disadvantage, is
that you have to write a new version for each type you want.
When the code in the body is exactly the same,
both of them say return a less than b, a, b.
So it's kind of redundant.
That's where function templates come in.
So a function template is a set of instructions
that tell the compiler how to generate a function when
it is called.
The functions are only generated if they are called.
If we write the template for smaller,
and we pass in-- we don't call it with a string,
it will never be generated from a string.
So here's the template function.
Notice first that every template function always
starts with template, type name, and then
some symbol you're going to use as a placeholder for your type.
T is really common.
U is really common.
But you can use larger names or ones that are more descriptive
if you want.
So this says the function smaller
is going to return a type of whatever type T is.
And it's going to take two arguments, a const T ref for a
and a const T ref for b.
And notice the code in here is exactly the same.
Now, templates have to be seen when your code compiles.
For that reason, they're generally
placed in a header file.
They are not pre-compiled like a regular function.
Now, there are two ways to call a template function.
Or specifically, there are two ways
to generate the function from the template.
When you call it, you can explicitly specify
the type to be used for T. So I could
call that function with smaller.
And then in angle brackets after the name, I could say string.
So generate a smaller function that uses string for T,
and then pass in frog and flea.
Now, that will write-- when you call the function,
it will write a version of smaller
that has the T replaced with string here.
So it will say string smaller.
Const string ref a, const string ref b, return a less than b.
It will write that function for you.
So that is called a template function.
This is a function template.
The function that's generated is called a template function.
Now, can you simply call it implicitly?
Yes, you can.
So if I call the function auto n equals smaller 3.46 and 3.45,
it will, in fact, give me back 3.45.
And that generates this function.
Double, remember, replaces the T with double,
replaces the a with double, the b with double.
And actually, it will replace it with const double ref,
const double ref b.
The reason we do the const in the template
is because we don't know what type T is going to be here.
And so we use the const T ref in case it's a library type.
It doesn't hurt it if it's a primitive type,
although it's not as efficient as it could be.
Now, a couple of problems with that.
First, the compiler cannot read your mind.
What if we said auto s equals smaller frog and flea?
If we do this, the compiler is going
to deduce type T as a character array instead of string.
And the code actually will not work.
So notice earlier-- so notice here
I'm finding the smaller frog and flea, and it doesn't work.
But here, I explicitly said, oh, I
want to use string for that type.
And it did work.
So the compiler can't read your mind.
The solution is to either explicitly instantiate it,
or you can add an overload of the function.
If you write an overloaded non-template function that
exactly matches the arguments here,
then this version will be used before the other version.
OK.
A couple more problems with deduction.
What happens when we do this?
Auto n equals smaller 3.46 and 4.
Well, that doesn't even compile.
T is supposed to be a double, like argument 1,
or an n, like argument 2.
And remember, let's look back at the template.
We have only one type name here, but two arguments
that are type T. So it's going to look at this one and say,
oh, no, it's a double.
Oh, no, it's an int.
It doesn't compile.
OK.
So how do we fix that?
Well, you don't have to make every argument the same type
parameter.
So let's say we have a double.
We don't have to make every argument the same type
parameter.
So I could say template.
I could create a type name named T, another type name named
U. And in this case, when I called it here,
A would be double, or T would be double, and U would be int.
Now, which one will it return?
Will it return an int or a double?
This actually is a little bit problematic.
The return type could be either T or U.
Starting in C++ 17, we can put auto as the return type here,
and it will allow compiler deduction.
If you look in your reader, you'll
see a version that will work with C++ 11 and 14.
This is called a trailing return type.
However, this function probably has
to decide either return an int or a double in this case.
Because in fact, what's going to happen
is to see if A is less than B. And if A is an int
and B is a double, your computer cannot actually compute this
without knowing which of those is a larger.
So the larger type will always be the type
that's returned in that case.
OK, let's do a couple of exercises
before we end up this lecture and our hour together.
So let me go back to our lecture exercise.
And these are some function templates
from Purdue University.
So we're going to write one function, exchange AB, which
has two parameters of the same type.
So we only need one template parameter.
A function which is instantiated from exchange
will exchange or swap these two parameters.
And then multiples, sum, x, and n.
The first type of parameters will
have the type represented by the function template type
parameter kind, or T. n will always be int.
The return type's void.
All parameters are passed by value,
except for sum, which is passed by reference.
A function instantiated from multiples
will compute 1 plus x plus 2x plus 3x and so forth to nx.
So let's go ahead and do that, although I don't remember
exactly how to solve that.
OK, so here's the first one.
We're going to exchange A and B. So for the templates,
we're going to write template type name T.
Looks like exchange doesn't return anything.
And so that's going to be T reference A and T reference B.
We'll create a temporary T object.
So T temp.
We'll initialize it with A. We'll say A equals B.
We'll say B equals temp.
And now we've exchanged the two values.
OK, so notice we can do it with ints.
We can do it with doubles.
We can do it with strings.
OK, so sum-- OK, so that is going to take template type
name.
They want kind for the type here,
I think, just to show you that you can use--
you don't need to use T. Void and kind reference sum.
And kind-- what was the second argument in that?
x, kind reference x, or kind x, test by value, and int n.
OK, so sum, let's set it to whatever value represents 0,
or the empty value.
For instance, if we wanted to sum strings,
do they do strings here?
No, they only do it with numbers,
because the expression is going to be 1 over.
So we're going to say sum equals 0.
Or is it?
Let's look at the expression.
So sum equals 1 plus x.
And it'll be converted to whatever type it is.
And then it's going to be x plus 2x plus 3x.
So write a loop for int i equals 1, so 1x, i less than
or equal to n, because we want nx, i plus plus,
sum equals sum plus i times x.
And I think that's all we'll have to do.
Down here it works, you can see, with doubles.
And it works with ints.
OK, let's try it.
OK, so that worked.
Here's swapping two ints, here's swapping two doubles,
here's swapping two strings.
Here is doing multiples with doubles,
here's doing multiples with integers.
All righty then, I believe that's all for today.
And so we will see you in the next lecture in lecture 15.